an investigation is underway after
another Colorado law enforcement officer
was killed in the line of duty hundreds
of mourners gathered last night to honor
El Paso County sheriff's deputy Micah
flick he is the third Colorado officer
to be shot dead in five weeks
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network CBS and shows us the string of
killings blatt good morning good morning
the 11-year veteran leaves behind a wife
and seven year old twins police say Flik
and other officers were investigating a
car theft when they encountered a
suspect first there was a struggle and
shots were fired I heard like a pop and
there was a pause and there was like pop
pop pop around 4:00 p.m. Monday shots
rang out in Colorado Springs
the first 9-1-1 call came from an
apartment building near the shooting one
civilian one Colorado Springs police
officer and two El Paso County sheriff's
deputies were injured during the
confrontation the suspect was shot and
killed along with deputy Mike Affleck
the father of seven-year-old twins was
killed on his 11th anniversary as a
police officer deputy flick was an
outstanding member of my agency and he
will be missed flick is the third
Colorado police officer gunned down in
the line of duty in the last five weeks
Douglas County sheriff's deputy Zachary
Parrish was killed on New Year's Eve and
Adams County deputy Keith gum was killed
on January 24th this has happened you
know all too often here in the last
couple months you know Randy shot and
his son Gavin were among the hundreds of
people who braved the cold to pay their
respects the deputy flick Monday night
deputy flick made the ultimate sacrifice
and taking care of all of us and so the
least we can do is is come out here and
and say thank you mourners waved flags
and saluted the passing cars as a solemn
police procession for flick rolled away
from the hospital tonight there is no
distinction between our uniforms
State Patrol Sheriff's Office and the
Colorado Springs Police Department our
hearts were all broken
Colorado Governor John Hickenlooper
ordered all flags in the state to fly at
half-staff
he also acknowledged the recent series
of police killings is having a grave
impact on the people of Colorado and
certainly our thoughts and prayers are
with everyone including those twins
green thank you one